oh it's gonna be a fun show tonight look
we told you last week that there was
something spicy brewing that it would
become official today guess what it did
Spice Girls are reuniting heading out on
toward the spice height on this set
right now is unbelievable I am pulling
out my t-shirts and my purses and
because this is the greatest
entertainment news story of all time in
my opinion it will be amazing but we
have one problem it will not be posh say
you'll be there well not before you
Beckham and now we know why you can't be
for a note now if we're going on to the
Spice Girls announced their UK stadium
tour in a video this morning
noticeably absent Victoria Beckham
so where's posh well source tells et
that Victoria isn't taking part in the
2019 reunion tour because quote she has
a family to look after and a business to
run
I wouldn't dress like that now and she
was pretty blunt with us she's moved on
from that flashy Spice Girls style we've
been there we've done that and we've
moved on Victoria has four kids with
husband David Beckham and we should
point out that all of the Spice Girls
are moms
we've all got children so it's very hard
to tall because we are my maids and we
don't like leaving them for two dogs in
fact Geri Halliwell had a son just last
year ET first met the Spice Girls in
1997 their Olympic reunion in 2012 got
fans excited about a tour we will be
doing stuff this year yes meanwhile Mel
B is stirring the pot she dressed up
like posh on Halloween holding a sign
that read no I am NOT going on tour she
also told a British talk show the 6 UK
concerts are just the beginning would
you like to do a world tour oh yeah we
are oh you are we go everywhere else in
the world but for right now it is just
the door is open for Victoria if she
finds herself available yeah so the door
is open she could change her mind so
many people are psyched about this tour
especially this little wannabe do you
recognize her that is Grammy winning
goddess Adele back when her wall was
devoted to the Spice Girls Adele posted
the shot saying quote I am great where'd
you do that dance to the Spice Girls
yeah yeah everyone knows that one you
know
[Music]